bravissima spetta lo prova proprio lui
ma che giocatore è sembrava si sognava
qua ho sognato fuori è arrivato lui no
ci metteva peccato perché c'era ancora
speranza si segnalava adesso così sai
basta che da bloccarlo ancora una volta
9 dopo finisce proprio addio che cosa
cinque le classi meno te lo giuro non
penso di poter fare una roba del genere
ho tenuto la palla arriva a domandargli
mantenuto la parola viva e questi erano
soltanto due dei tiri che ho fatto
perché io sono un calciatore mancato che
mai cominciare volevo dirvi che sono con
thomas quindi il ragazzo che ha fatto
con make up ed alla settimana scorsa e
stiamo giocando a rocket league erano un
po che non ci giocavo mi chiediate di
portarlo da settimane quindi ho voluto
farci un episodio spero che vi piaccia
la buona visione
beh guarda guarda problema vi lasciamo
problema importante ragazzi mi sono
veramente rotto le palle basta mai preso
fresco ma
dai dai dai dai dai forza tutti in mezzo
tutti così vai così bella e così tocca
ora tocca ai map al 100
la butta e mezzo incredibile deve
toccarla oggi si sogna sono i media in
mezzo ai tranesi incredibile porca vacca
che botta di me tirato volevi 51
curatissime e se ne vanno forte che
tanto abbiamo la sua prossima avversaria
e si va col match in numero 3 una
vittoria una sconfitta per i nostri
supereroi suo ok caso è successo non ho
capito neanch'io dell'imparare la
situazione alla bella brilla solo
parzialmente parata paranà rock ha fatto
bene non so se mi riesce quasi quasi 4
bello a2 bravissimo centro no arrivato
di coda ognuna forse non entra mi sono
cavata ma che sfiga all'incrocio col
pallonetto all'incrocio bravissimi è
troppo lunga ancora lì ma lei no lei non
è chiamata 26 mi aspetto di esserci
invece non si può peccato era gol
penserà guasto se non avremo neanche più
veloce di te quindi lo fare cioè 1 2 1 2
1 e noi sì che ci credo no mai né tua no
non entrambe ramo tabaton
lannes trattati con ritmi michele
passato bravissimo a una cosa ottima
ok 16 69 cv e cioè lui ma lo è anche
l'andiamo a vincere e vuole un tocco
posto disintegrati era franco così a
dieci secondi dalla fine
otto gli ho fatto male fatti mobbing big
bamboo è motivatissimo questa partita
credo che una mia presa bene la spinta
save as occhio occhio che rischia di
perderla pure tranquillo non la vede mai
finito qui che non è finito sto gioco e
un tocco deve farlo ha detto bene siamo
risiamo siamo il nob si aspetta ed a
cambiare dà fastidio
e lì ci dovrei arrivare io ma non ci
credo ma fa niente ma fai bene o luca
vacca che brutta roba ho visto tutta la
serie c ma dov'è la madonna bravissimo
bravissima spetta lo prova proprio lui
che non è teniamo il risultato ragazzo
ha rimbalzato schifosissimo veniamo
risultato una sega pali supero palla e
mezzo ma bella gli occhi o chiocchio
mammamia bravissimo ha evitato una roba
in credenza che ci faceva lì c'era tanta
ma valeva tolta ma niente non gli hanno
tolto per un millimetro salve grande
profeta auto perfetto tornata grandi tom
grandi perfetto non avrei saputo
sfruttare meglio bravissimo è stata
giocata da manuale
a dover volare è sicuro che bella
giornata per fare gol
una donna che sarebbe l'uomo volesse
tirare perfetto era esattamente questo
che doveva fare
bravissimo quando il tuo compagno
incerto e l'anci lui e la palla e non
stavo capendo neanche stava succedendo
si era bello vice solo da solo si si
tragga un tre a zero così palla rimane
lì di valore
la piazza 4 a 0 portare incredibile a
tre gol in 35 secondi continuiamo il
record mi sa che a vedere questi due
effettivamente 55 in 49 secondi
attenzione eccolo ma paolo solo 6 110
secolo infatti secondo me ci arriva
addirittura la facciamo che qui se non
abbandonavano rimandata in questa
bellissima è la vista anche per la prima
volta le nuova di un po prima partita su
stata partorita in porta attenzione
bravo che mi attira del falco non va
addirittura benedetti far rosicare
quando la tocchi sta per uscire ma non
esce troppo convinto di riuscire a
parallelo con l'inter aveva questi che
cosa sta facendo ma chi sono
semmai diamo si va all'attacco come vi
bravo bravo sì voglio oggi dio
poi uno non fare sul web sono turbo come
viene viene
pp d'acqua dovesse affidato scusami
avuto favori ma lui è bravo così
intendeva
si riparte e sogno e l'ho toccata carlos
è un po di tempo ce l'hanno lasciata
ponte 26 non entrare dentro entra si sa
che dopo la sconfitta di prima c'è un po
abbassato il rango tensione bello ma
secondo me secondo me no o niente che
succede niente sono morte dopo questa
facciamo uno vivono qualcuno mi aiuti
via o che si fa a uno viola è strano
perché quando parti non arriva l'altro
c'è macelli prova non validi combattuta
di quanto si pensi
winehouse e fa pure e ronaldinho lo
prenderemo in giro noi dice no mi vendi
e tutto ciò tuttavia attenzione guarda
che la notte era un'idea ottima ci
sarebbe stata scattata da gol
spetta ora ho paura eccolo no l'ho
toccata ma li vai vai così così
quanta marchi just me ma cos'è successo
cioè si capisce le distruzioni il tuo
veicolo mi ha impedito di toccare il
pallone non omega esatto
gli regala un tiro a porta vuota la
piazza bene no malagoli gorgoni prego
vai così e così e lo dico al signor al
gol
ecco io facciamo un nono ma che me la
lancio si notano corsa da diverse
ti è piaciuto questo passaggio ma che lo
cercano la tocchi ok spareggio ne
convengo al primo che lo farà vincere
neanche per scherzo all'ancora l'umidità
tiro
prego inciampa fai qualcosa si è questo
che ci sostiene nel niente
quindi ragazzi questa è la mia virus
rocket league non lo porto molto spesso
però diciamo che quando lo porto e
perché cazzeggio con gli amici è un
gioco di quelli che faccio con i miei
amici senza registrare di solito però mi
sia piaciuto il video spero vi siate
divertiti ragazzi cose ci piace il
momento mi piace anche valigia come da
tradizione si schieri ci vediamo questo
video la ragazza
[Musica]
no